escribe el número representado por los
bloques que se muestran tenemos estos
dos cuadrados grandes y estos renglones
bueno en lugar de estar contando
cuadrado por cuadrado vamos a ver
cuántos cuadrados hay de este lado 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 y de este otro lado hay 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 10 x 10 son 100 en
este cuadrado y 5 hábitos y este otro
cuadrado es igual a este así que entre
los dos hay 200 cuadros viendo los
renglones tenemos que cada renglón
simplemente por el ver el tamaño el
ancho es el mismo que el de este cuadro
por lo que cada renglón tiene 10
cuadritos tenemos 200 cuadros acá más 10
20 30 40 tenemos 240 cuadros y ustedes
me pueden decir bueno cuál es el punto
de este ejercicio solo estamos contando
bloques pero si se fijan en nuestra
cantidad este 2 no es sólo un 2 está en
la posición de las centenas
antenas y por estar en esta posición
este 2 vale 200 ahora este 4 está en la
posición de las decenas y simplemente
por estar en ese lugar en esa posición
este 4 vale 40 que son estos renglones
de acá y aquí bueno en las unidades
tenemos ser no tenemos unidades acá
vamos hacer otro ejercicio similar con
otros cuadritos ahora tenemos estos
cuadros pues vamos a aplicar lo mismo
tenemos uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis
siete ocho nueve diez y aquí también
tenemos diez cuadros 10 por 10 100 este
cuadro de acá me representa un 100 sin
cuadritos tenemos de renglones uno dos
tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho nueve
diez cuadritos por cada renglón y
tenemos uno dos tres cuatro cinco
renglones de todos estos tenemos 50
cuadritos y tenemos cuadros sueltos uno
dos tres cuatro
estos son cuatro nuestra cantidad
representada por estos cuadros son 154 y
de nuevo este uno no es un uno está en
las centenas
y por el simple hecho de estar en esta
posición es un 100 el 5 está en las
decenas por lo que son 50 y el 4 está en
las unidades y este sí representa un 4
porque está en las unidades nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo